you're dark I was thinking tonight could
be a good night for sex night possibly
Thursdays
Stephen London how's the new Opera
coming along good great great we had
discussed seeing a first draft of the
score in two weeks is it still all right
I'm suffering from a temporary blockage
at the moment
no turn it back on
good
fat
is he all right he had a total breakdown
after his last opera
I can't do this
we need to take a walk jolt your brain
out of its little rad pattern interact
with a stranger okay honey I have a
patient bye
are we going that way I keep imagining
you naked I don't know if you want to
hear more details about these images no
[Music]
I bet every one of these people has a
story for an opera and then Levi what do
you do I operated Tempo the wrong hands
this tug is a deadly weapon
I'm addicted to romance isn't everybody
I've been arrested for stalking I had to
go to rehab and uh not supposed to be
doing this
can't believe that actually happened I
mean she seduced me right she's a witch
the demented tugboat captain who knows
men to her Tugboat and kills them
beneath them I loved it how did you come
up with that
that was really angry at you and now it
turns out I'm your Muse oh see I'll
never leave you
um
I love cleaning cleaning is close to
Godliness where my patients are talking
I imagine getting inside their heads
with disinfectant and just scrubbing
them down
your tugboat captain came to see me I'm
in Love no no just admit that I had a
magic effect on you my imagination came
up with the story my talent wrote the
music I mean you don't kill men and eat
them do you well I haven't yet
I know I can't resist a romantic story
even if I'm not in it
[Music]